[Musique]
au maroc azila signifie l'oublier et
c'est vrai que la ville a été longtemps
oublié quelque part entre tanger au nord
et le grand port de larache au sud
[Musique]
aziza est encore plus oublier l'hiver
quand les vacanciers ont cadenassé leur
résidence d'été mais la ville ne
s'endort pas tout à fait quelques
pêcheurs anime encore les ruelles de la
médina
à sa manière francis est aussi un
pêcheur
cela fait sept ans qu'il s'est installé
à assilah pour y faire une précieuse
récolte celle du corail
francis et une poignée de plongeurs en
donner à la ville d'asilah un titre de
notoriété qui l'a fait sortir de l'oubli
au maroc
elle est la capitale de ce que l'on
appelle ici lord shen un nom qui
transporte dans tout le monde arabe
une caravane de croyances et de légendes
ailleurs on l'appelle aussi l'or rouge
comme cette récolte sanguine qui teinte
les vitrines d'asilah
[Musique]
dans la médina le visage de francis est
devenu familier des silhouettes du corps
ailleurs inséparable de son sac fait
partie du décor alors au départ au
départ j'étais dans un petit village à
karen et je voulais de jockey et ma mère
a pas voulu m'a dit c'est un métier
dangereux
andrieu risques et j'ai cherché une
chose et je suis tombé sur une école de
plongée dans ce village et j'ai fini
comme plongeur de là bas j'ai suivi un
itinéraire à peu près réguliers les
travaux publics l'offshore avec
l'offshore j'ai travaillé un peu sur
toutes les mers du monde ont fait le
pacifique l'atlantique à la mer du nord
golfe persique ensuite j'ai rencontré un
collègue qui m'a présenté le corail
ça m'a bien plu et on est venu
travailler sur le maroc on est resté
quelques temps nord du maroc et depuis
on est sûr assis là de quelques années
et on attend 40 et de corail on reste
rare hier
voilà une enfant solène et une femme
kate y partagent la vie nomade de
francis
[Musique]
les rangs art date de l'époque
portugaise avant que la ville ne tombe
aux mains des espagnols
la langue hispanique est resté certaine
tradition aussi comme cette habitude
qu'ont les habitants de déambuler en fin
de journée le dard en passer
[Musique]
les femmes sous le regard des hommes
7h02 près des bijouteries
si le corail est une pierre que l'on
regarde la filiale est belle c'est aussi
un porte bonheur qui grâce à lui on se
protège des mauvaises influences et des
êtres maléfiques ou plusieurs arrière
boutiques se sont transformés en
ateliers des jeunes d'asilah se sont
initiés à l'art de la taille sous la
houlette de larbi un ancien commerçant
fasciné par le corail qui le bordaient
lorsqu'on est sur la berge il qu'on
regarde la mer on ne voit que la surface
[Musique]
on ne sait rien des profondeurs on ne
les voit pas c'est pareil pour le corail
il y à bien sa couleur rouge mais on a
beau le regarde et on ne peut percer son
mystère
la passion du corail a fixé des
voyageurs derrière les remparts des
bijoutiers mais aussi d'autres hommes
venus de loin juan paquet là le galicien
ivan ancien plongeur de la mer noire par
lou l'italien georges laurentien marque
marin breton
fils et petit fils de marin breton juan
l'espagnol daddy de tétouan ancien
pêcheur de méron une dizaine de
plongeurs confirmés parmi les derniers
corps ailleurs itinérant au monde
[Musique]
et il est à francis bien sûr les corps
ailleurs viennent au port tous les
matins à l'aube et décident chacun après
avoir scruté la mère de s'embarquer ou
de rester à quai
cela fait une semaine que les plongeurs
ne sont pas sortis à cause de chergui
avant que tous les marins redoute et qui
prend souvent ses quartiers dans la
région
[Musique]
ce matin les conditions sont bonnes pour
une sortie en mer
[Musique]
en quelques années près de 20 tonnes de
cette eau rouge ont été arrachés à
l'océan
d'ordinaire le corail rouge se pêche en
méditerranée
asile a approuvé que le corail avait
franchi le détroit de gibraltar et se
répandait le long des côtes de
l'atlantique on n'en exploitent même un
petit fils ont tout au sud près du cap
vert
on m'a pas vraiment pour la promenade on
part pour chercher du corail
les jeux on a l'espoir de tomber dessus
reste toujours le rêve aussi de trouver
sur la grosse branche de corail
tous les matins quand il saute à l'eau
va tu dis je vais tomber dessus
chaque fois que tu tournes à kuan proche
du nirvana et puis tous les jours on
passe à côté
mais le rêve il reste là quand même
l'oeil rivé sur le sondeur qui reproduit
sur son écran tout le relief des fonds
marins francis choisi de plonger au
large du cap spartel la pointe nord
ouest de l'afrique
le courant y est beaucoup plus fort que
sur la zone de pêche habituelle en face
d'asile mais l'eau y est aussi bien plus
clair
enfin vous savez on va pas inventer
invente un peu
bon
[Applaudissements]
un corps ailleurs travaillé longtemps
pour former un marin capable de
l'assister durant toutes les phases de
la plongée et surtout en cas d'urgence
ne savent pas connaissons travail et les
deux hommes économise gestes et paroles
pour se comprendre
la plongée a commencé francis est déjà
isolé du monde en surface
et la touche au corps est une des plus
belles plongées qui peut faire une des
plongées limite vraiment limite où tu es
tout seul avec toi y a personne derrière
[Musique]
à
les plongeurs d'asilah doit souvent des
cendres à plus de 80 mètres de
profondeur pour espérer trouver un filon
d'or rouge
tous travaillent à l'air comprimé en
respirant ce gaz les plongeurs
ressentent les effets de la narcose
l'ivresse des profondeurs
dès qu'ils dépassent les 50 m
comme abattu par un alcool surpuissant
celui qui en souffre perd parfois
connaissance sans avoir le moindre
réflexe de survie
[Musique]
mais les gestes de france y sont
mécaniques et les réflexes au départ des
milliers de plongée
le corail d'asilah est apprécié pour sa
teinte sanglant sous l'eau cet animal
étonnant offre toute une palette de
couleur passant du blanc quand il est en
fleurs alors en jeu quand il est cueilli
plus tard à la surface il dévoilera en
rouge vermillon sa dernière couleur
francis à une réserve d'air qui lui
accorde une vingtaine de minutes de
travail au fond ce sont les bulles qui
renseigne les marins sous la position
des plongeurs
il faut être vigilant le courant a vite
fait d'éloigner un homme sous la mer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le travail le plus fastidieux commence à
la fin de la révolte
il faut remonter progressivement et
faire des paliers de décompression pour
accoutumer l'organisme à une pression
normale
[Musique]
le parachute remonte seul avec la
cueillette de corail francis devra
patienter plus d'une heure sous l'eau
m
francisque son dernier palier à 9 mètres
avant de remonter à la surface en ceux
des comprimés à 3 m
[Applaudissements]
il
il n'y a pas de temps francis à quatre
ou cinq minutes pour se déshabiller
avant de s'enfermer dans le caisson de
décompression une minute de perdue et
c'est le risque de l'évanouissement de
la paralysie
dans le caisson francis replonge
artificiellement à la profondeur où elle
a abandonné son palier
c'est une méthode très risqué mais qui
al'avantage de protéger le plongeur du
froid et de gagner beaucoup de temps
[Musique]
fermée
et
[Musique]
il
francis et les autres sont des nomades
de la mer les années depuis le départ de
leur port d'origine
ce conte j'ai plutôt envie de retourner
de retourner là bas parce que je
retrouverai pas ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
dit c'est quoi d'une dizaine d'années
une quinzaine d'années des attaches pour
le travail même des attaches affectives
tu en as beaucoup plus sur l'extérieur
que sur le que sur la france n'est des
gens sans frontières on suit on suit le
corail en fin de compte on suit le
corail notre pays d'attaché la mer donc
partout où il ya de l'eau ils risquent
dirait du corail et y aura des corps
yeux
dans un clan comme dans celui des
corailleurs il ya toujours les anciens
ceux qui ont tout connu tout vécu
à pippa asie là il y a des 10 le
marocain 60 ans l'ancien pêcheur de meo
qui a découvert le corail au large du
port et marcon l'italien est ce qu avait
là des langues aux stars tu sais quand
je suis arrivé ici
les pêcheurs de langoustes remontée du
corail dans leurs filets mais il le
jeter à la mer
il ne savait pas que ça avait de la
valeur
ça les encombrer alors il le jeter à la
mer
j'ai commencé par leur en acheter un
prix dérisoire
et puis j'ai plongé c'est comme ça que
toute aventure a commencé depuis
dix-huit bateaux sont arrivés et avec
eux près de 60 plongeuse oui il n'y a
pas de limitation de plongeurs qu'est-ce
qui se passe le corail baisse de valeur
il se raréfient et tu sais qu'il faudra
plus de 100 ou 150 ans pour que les
branches reprennent une taille normale
à ce moment là on sera tous morts
les réserves s'épuisent les autorités ne
protège pas grand chose mais la plupart
des grands corps ailleurs reste encore
sur place
comme si l île à pouvait promettre
d'autres saisons miraculeuse
francis est de ceux là mais il ya aussi
roanne l'espagnol véritable phénomène de
la nature qui reste deux fois plus
longtemps que les autres au fond de
l'eau c'est un moment fantastique a
aussi la main de la fortune en 8 ans
croit nos remontées près de deux tonnes
de chorales
[Musique]
je me sens un peu chez moi ici je calque
la télévision espagnole
les gens parlent espagnol surtout des
vieux qui me racontent la vie d'avant
l'indépendance
il me raconte des choses des histoires
du passé
en fait ça va je me sens ici chez moi
dans le clan des corailleurs il ya les
nomades comme francis et il ya les
autres qui s'installe lors d'une escale
c'est ce qu'a fait roanne en ouvrant la
plus grande fabrique d'asile et en se
mariant avec une femme de la ville
à noter les deux confessions j'ai
investi dans un atelier de confection
nous employons près de 100 personnes
dépend de l'époque de la conjoncture
économique
parfois la demande est forte parfois
aidées crise entre le maroc et l'espagne
qui nous perturbe comme le problème de
la pêche et des camionnettes
en ce moment nous sommes obligés
d'envoyer notre production par la france
et cela revient très cher
voilà quelques fois nous n'avons pas
grand chose pour faire tourner la
fabrique parfois réelles occasions même
de l'argent
le vent tombe à pic pour renflouer la
société
mais les acheteurs venus de naples sont
de plus en plus difficile et discutent
âprement un corail qui vont entre trois
et quatre ans l'avait laissé mon
accession
en attendant de conclure une vente dont
les négociations durent parfois
plusieurs jours craindre retourne au
corail ce matin il est le premier à
s'habiller pour plonger
allez ans
[Musique]
francis à changer de bateau après une
avarie les plongeurs passe d'un bateau à
un autre d'un armateur à l'autre sans
véritable règle du show l'essentiel pour
tout le monde et de trouver du corail
il en reste on va essayer de prendre en
grèce nous paye ou là à 60 mètres en
tête à peu près et son second au mur
un pack
[Musique]
tous les plongeurs recherchent les
cailloux qui ont été oubliés depuis le
début de l'exploitation mais les
occasions sont rares et chacun récolte
aujourd'hui les branches de corail qu'il
jugeait autrefois trop modeste pour lui
[Musique]
au début de l'exploitation certains
corps ailleurs remonté parfois quinze à
20 kilos le corail et s'épuise aide à
menou vrai leur panier
[Musique]
des milliers de planches et ont nettoyé
les fonds les roches ont changé de
couleur
les francis traque la moindre tache
rouge
[Musique]
ces rochers ont été visités à plusieurs
reprises et cryer repique c'est-à-dire
repasse les uns derrière les autres
la plongée s'annonce mer malgré la
visite de grottes sous marines francis
ne découvre que du petit corail qui ne
ramassent pas pourtant à quelques milles
dollars
les bancs de corail sont intactes car
ils sont situés sur la route des cargos
aux portes de gibraltar ou dans des
zones de courant trop fort ce sont de
véritables sanctuaires pour francis
c'est une plongée à vide
où
il est des jours où on verrait surgir
[Musique]
des journées comme celle là il y en a de
plus en plus souvent à assilah les
premières rumeurs de départ commence
alors à circuler sur les quais et dans
la ville chez francis on n'en parle pas
encore même si cathy sa femme voit de
moins en moins de querelles du passé
entre les mains il ya quatre ans les
plongeurs péché par journée ça veut dire
en une plongée etc c'est qu'ils ont
maintenant si tu fais un kilo par jour
c'est magnifique mais tu peux revenir
avec 200 g ou 100 g ou avec rien c'est
là où est le problème
ak c'est pourquoi tu gagnes de l'argent
même si tu rates un deux trois jours
dans le mois d'août après faire la fête
tu t'en fous tu es que maintenant tu
peux plus me permettre c'est un petit
peu près c'est bon les gens sont un peu
renfermé
chez eux les hommes restent plutôt chez
eux pour réparer entretenir leur
matériel il y a moins d'argent pour
s'équiper et l'heure est à la bricole
il nous reste parfois que les souvenirs
des années fastes d'asile à la fin des
années 80
[Musique]
francis et ketty rejoignait le clan des
corailleurs qui venait de se former dans
l'escale d'asile la fête avec son
cortège de file et d'alcool rythme et
les nuits les corps ailleurs quand
l'argent se gagner au bout de quelques
plongées
[Rires]
[Musique]
la ville vivait son âge d'or et les
terrasses se parer de rouge quand les
plongeurs faisait sécher le corail après
des plongées fructueuse
chez francis gatty voyez souvent passer
de la pacotille
c'est comme ça que les corps ailleurs
nomme les branches exceptionnel c'était
l'époque de l'argent facile et les
arnaques
quelques semaines après cette vente chez
francis se négociant a disparu à
l'étranger emportant avec lui près de
600 kg de corail
[Musique]
cook est capable
je
la fin des années 80 c'était les années
d'insouciance
bien avant les accidents et les nuages
sombres qui allait couvrir le ciel
d'asile
pas mal de jeunes qui sont venus
travailler et six ou sept jeunes
plongeurs qui sont passés ici on sur les
six ou sept qui sont passés ici là
encore trois qui sont bons il y en a un
qui est resté paralysé il est paralysé à
vie et ça vient du problème que ici au
départ on a fait du corail sur des qui
font 45 50 m où tout le monde et est
capable de plonger
et quand on a commencé à prendre du
fonds ces jeunes sont mon expérience mon
manque de métier et quand il commence à
prendre du fonds en plongeant à l'air
mais qui peut pas se permettre ça
pardonne pas et là il ya de la casse du
gaz armand
chaque année plusieurs corps ailleurs
font leur grande plongée sans fin
celle qui jette un voile sur la ville
les accidents ou en brie
caractéristiques celui d'un concert
funèbre de compresseurs qui tente
désespérément d'alimenter en mer un
plongeur accidenté alors le quai
accueille des plongeurs les marins et
une veuve
tout le monde tous les plongeurs pas ça
coûte et à cannes à strophes les
accidents ont eu une oreille
déséquilibré
un vendeur un détendeur qui conquit qui
explose sa recette sont des accidents
matériels qui t'arrive et à chaque fois
tu penses à côté de la catastrophe
à chaque fois ça ça arrive à tous les
plongeurs bon mais quand tu es habitué
et tu es conscient de ça avec le métier
tu tu t'en tires tu t'en tires bien tu
arrives à d'échappée il devient dur d
échapper quand le corail se pêche de
plus en plus profond quand l'expérience
andorre la vigilance c'est à ce moment
que les plongeurs tutoie la mort ce
jour-là pour le doyen des plongeurs
d'asilah des 10 ou mauvaise
décompression et c'est le drame
dadis en sortira de justesse son
accident n'a entraîné qu'une paralysie
passagère mais ce n'est jamais bénin
pour le plongeur et cela nourrit des
doutes chez les autres puis qu'est-ce
que je fais pas ça va être moi est bon à
décès de la diva qui dans étudie en fin
de compte oui où on m'a il a répondu
faire ça et s'il a fait ça moi je le
ferai pas et tu te rassure en me disant
que à toi ça n'arrivera pas et qui
retourne dans l'eau parce que si tu
retournes pas tout de suite tu
redescends plus après et puis y'a le
corail elle conseille quand même ça ça
lui l'importance parce que tu dis ça
tatillon c'est un peu un aimant aussi
donc quoi qu'il arrive un corps ailleurs
il retournera toujours pour le corail
c'est une maladie de korian c'est un
virus
[Musique]
alors
asile à ce souci peau des vies
sacrifiées pour le corail dans ce sport
ancestral temps de pêcheurs ont disparu
que les accidents en mer font partie de
la vie de la cité asie la vie doucement
entre ces marchés et son économie du
tourisme les habitants regardent les
plongeurs avec un certain détachement
étranger à cette fièvre du corail qui ne
quitte jamais celui qu'elle a visités
comme francis marco ne se débarrasse pas
de cette fièvre
même si lui renonce à plonger pour
l'instant après plusieurs greffes
médicale bien sûr je trahis mon bateau
je bricole mais dans le même temps
j'écoute les nouvelles j'ai contacté
beaucoup de pêcheurs beaucoup je suis
monté jusqu'à la mauritanie est lui
monté jusqu'à dakhla je termine 1200 km
part de 4 l'été presque sénégal pour
contacter des montes il à la mer la mer
ici 50 personnes et là il a posé la tête
d'un an
il faut tout faute ou redécouvrir ce
réel sur place d'un droit il est bon
chez il ya les climats ya tout la mer
mais surtout parce que ces tarifs qui
s'est presque sourd qui vont découvrir
la maison tout neuf il ya des corail
dans trois vieilles endroit vierge et
moi je suis déjà sur le boss
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les jours de grand vent les plongeurs et
par leur matériel ou tu raques le corail
ailleurs francis accompagne marco ah ben
younes à trois heures de route d'asile à
des rumeurs circulent sur de récentes
découvertes de corail
[Musique]
la main
durant l'époque coloniale espagnole les
baleines qui empruntaient le détroit de
gibraltar été pêchés et des possédants
le village de ben younès aujourd'hui
l'ancien baleinière tombe doucement en
ligne
[Musique]
mark connaît bien les lieux il avait
plongé ici il ya plus de vingt ans
pirates sans autorisation à cette époque
benyounes était le tout premier site de
pêche au corail du maroc
dans la région les habitants prétendent
que les romains l'avaient déjà exploité
à de faibles profondeurs
mais je vais voir
rappelez moi c'est pas que je pense m le
village ne vit plus que de contrebande
avec l'enclavé espagnole de ceuta
derrière la crique trafics en tous
genres
seule une poignée de pêcheurs continuent
à alimenter le village qu'un poisson
genre d'effets record nettoie report des
corail
c'était un couple se tenait à moore d'un
amour
les familles sont pas contents je
voulais te remets à peu près la nuit il
est tellement désespérée
il sait tirer ils se tiraient la bourre
avec ayew tour et sans grever les
sorties il a donné les couleurs les
rousses pour les corail la mer s'il peut
être encore de leurs rouges du martian
ce que francis et marcoux sont venus
demander aux pêcheurs
cadel peut te quitte ensuite la rentrée
avec le filet pour les langues aux
défilés accroche les rochers il y en a
beaucoup
tu en prends une fois de temps en temps
où tous les jours non non pas tous les
jours pas souvent
toujours au même endroit non partout
devant l'as tu pense qu'il y en a deux
plus grands non je ne pense pas aller
asile en asie là il semble aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y en a presque plus à vos wii le
corail d'asile a été très grand
[Musique]
les niveaux
quand
c'est vrai quasi là les pêcheurs
accroche de moins en moins de travail
dans leurs filets
pourtant il représente pour ces hommes
une source de revenus complémentaires
[Musique]
ce sont tous et non les plongeurs qui
vendent leur récolte aux bijoutiers
d'asile quand leur fils et révèle un
rocher prometteur il s'en suit parfois
de surprenantes négociations comme celle
qui réunit un patron pêcheur avec marco
combien tu demandes pour ton information
20 millions pour 20 millions je donne
l'emplacement de cette roche jeu les
relever s'il ya du corail mais s'il
n'est pas de grimper rien il n'y a pas
de problème c'est dans votre zone de
plongée je suis le seul à connaître
l'endroit
tu peux partir chercher avec une sonde
avec beaucoup de chance tu pourras
trouver en tout cas cet endroit je le
vendrais mais je ne le dirai à personne
les corps ailleurs hésitent à investir
pour acheter des lieux de pêche
mais ces informations optimiste décide
quelques-uns comme francis à rester
exploiter la zone pour découvrir
d'autres filon d'or rouge
il faut seulement s'organiser et trouver
comme marque l'ancien coéquipier de
francis des moyens pour les localiser
l'appareil en a tous la zone du détroit
ici et si on n'agit pas le temps et nous
on se trouve ici d'un asile à tous ces
points là qui apparaissent maintenant
c'est tout des plongées qu'on a
effectués nous et aussi l'avantagé que
quand je passe à côté de deux bouts et
d'autres bateaux ou dans la zone où
travaillent d'autres bâton je le mets en
mémoire et comme ça je sais bon cette
zone elle est travaillée par tel bateau
tu vois là les points sont regroupés
dont l'a sûrement il ya du corail il
existait déjà
alors moi le but ça va était par exemple
tu vois la croix là je vais essayer
d'exploiter par ici si je vois que c'est
un peu délaissé et comme un jeu
électronique de gosse tu vois le bateau
qui se déplacent tous un peu par là
c'est la même chose tu l'envoies tu veux
si tu es parmi les points déjà exploité
tout c'est ça qui est intéressant
je sais que cette année ça nous a servi
on a fait au moins la moitié de la
saison grâce à l'appareil
qu'est ce que la zone est entre été très
travaillé
mais l approche de l'hiver la plupart
des corailleurs ont déjà quitté asie là
daddy se remet de son accident de
plongée et regarde partir les nomades de
la mer
les compagnons d'un temps après huit
années de pêche il ne reste plus
beaucoup de corail asie là il est de
plus en plus difficiles à pêcher il faut
descendre à plus de 80 mètres pour le
trouver en une journée on parvenait à
pêcher 5 à 7 kilos
tout le monde y trouvait son compte les
armateurs et les plongeurs aujourd'hui
avec un seul kilo c'est trop difficile
et alors beaucoup d'entre eux sont
partis à la recherche d'autres sites
certains sont allés à cadix en espagne
on y aurait trouvé du corail mais on
n'est pas sûr il y en a même qui sont
partis travailler en algérie et en grèce
aussi pour nous qui restons si dieu le
veut on espère trouver rapidement un
nouveau filon
[Musique]
pour la famille de francis l'heure est
aussi au départ
les valises sont toujours prêtes et il
faut envisager rapidement une prochaine
escale sous la route du corail avec le
coréen et tout c'est chouette c'est bien
mais maintenant c'est fini il n'y a plus
d' aventure il ne peut rien et justement
va par exemple ce n'est plus à des bébés
dans une petite fille a maintenant est
parle arabe
elle va à l'école de tout à l'heure à
l'école espagnole elsa au style aussi de
français dont se serait bien temps que
si un jour on part elle elle en profite
qu elles puissent apprendre encore le
centre et que en compte tous les trois
avec mon mari on apprend dans la version
différente avec d'autres gens de tétouan
remonte à salta même motif tout ça ça a
été travaillé il ya du corail mes petits
maintenant on a toute la zone asie là
alors montant jusqu ici et là bon ça
commence à venir après avoir alors vu
qu'il ya du corail maintenant sur
l'atlantique
cette coutume est nettoyé lorsqu'on
essayait d'aider a décidé carrément au
sud on comprend la pointe et fait
résonner entre tarfaya et dakhla
oui mais c'est tout ça il n'y a pas de
n'est pas de porc comment sont les
villes où ils viivent on l'annoncé déjà
vu là c'est important quand même un bon
la confiance dans là aussi c'est tout ça
c'est sa passion sa soeur toute cette
zone couverte urbaine csu remonte ici on
retombe sur dheune tonnes et on a
commencé les maisons des écoles les
écoles on va les écoles je pense que si
on travaille par là les femmes vous
resterez basé sur laâyoune
ça nous coûtera moins cher et pas de
magasin courir
[Rires]
je peux
l'éclat de l'or rouge a illuminé les
siècles depuis l'antiquité
mais aujourd'hui le métier de plongeurs
s'éteint il ne reste que quelques
dizaines de corps ailleurs dans le monde
le métier se ranime parfois au gré de
nouveaux filons qui attise la fièvre du
corail
comme un irréductible nomades de la mer
francis le désirent une fois de plus se
rompre les amarres et de poursuivre sa
route en y entraînant sa famille
francis i am as une richesse que sa
fille conserve au fond des yeux un
chapelet d'escale rouge comme le corail
sur le fil d'une vie sans attaches
pour les habitants des dealers le corail
aura été une parenthèse dans une
histoire discrète et derrière ses
remparts la ville redeviendra l'oublier
le poumon
l'escale d'asilah aura duré longtemps
pour les plongeurs une escale de sueur
et de sang mais une escale de plus dans
une vie de liberté
tu te fais un peu l'habitude eudois bon
l'argent
ouais on y vient et on vit mal en même
temps parce qu'on n'en profite pas on
est pris 7 8 mois sur le métier
dimanche onze mois par an on est tenu
par les conditions météorologiques donc
tu te dis je peux pas me partir en
vacances je veux faire ceci parce qu'il
faut que je travaille était toujours
tenue parce que par ce de corps
et tu te tiens là parce que tu dis si je
loupe une journée google après louise in
mais c'est pire que l' usine cesser plus
prenantes lusignois rien et à la fin du
compte tu t'aperçois que tu as passé ta
vie à quoi au corps et c'est lui qui va
bouffer il a bouffé l'état ou mettant
est content notation c'est pourtant tire
une amertume temps est content tu en es
content tu as les gens qui partent en
vacances qui vont se balader ou
n'importe quoi toi t'es sur la mer tous
les jours on était content de son sort
cette liberté d'action que j'aime dans
ce métier je la paie cher mais
j'appellerai encore plus cher s'il
fallait que va payer plus cher bien sûr
ça métier de liberté sabri
[Musique]
à korian et la chorale y'a pas de pays
n'a pas de prix seul pays qui là où ils
braillent on lui a pas de frontières
[Musique]